CHRIS DIBONA: Hi, my name
is Chris DiBona.
I look after a lot of open
source stuff at Google.
But you're not here for me.
You're here for the incredibly
large number of people we have
on this stage.
And we're gonna start
from the far left--
my left your right--
with Dan.
Dan, introduce yourself
and pass it down.
DAN MORRILL: Hello.
I would like to, first, thank
you on behalf of the entire
Android team for being here to
hear us speak today instead of
being downstairs collecting
your free hardware.
So thank you for that.
I'm Dan Morrill.
I do things.
RETO MEIER: I'm Reto Meier.
I'm the tech lead for the
developer relations team.
REBECCA ZAVIN: Hi I'm
Rebecca Zavin.
I'm the tech lead for the
Android systems team.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: My name is
Ficus Kirkpatrick and I'm a
software engineer
on Google Play.
DIANNE HACKBORN: My name is
Dianne Hackborn and I work on
the application framework.
XAVIER DUCROHET: I'm
Xavier Duchrohet.
I'm the tech lead for the
SDK and developer tools.
FRED CONTADA: I'm
Fred Contada.
I'm the tech lead
manager for sync
accounts and data messaging.
MICHAEL SALISKY: I'm
Michael Salisky.
I'm a product manager
on Google Play.
DAVE BURKE: I'm Dave Burke,
engineering director for
platform software and
most accurately
described as overhead.
JAMES: Hi my name is James.
I'm the tech lead
for media team.
CHRIS DIBONA: You can just keep
hold of that and pass it
amongst yourselves.
So the way this is going to
work, we have a number of
questions from the moderator
instance, which I'm going to
draw from in between your going
to the microphones and
asking questions.
It is a fireside chat,
hence the fire.
This is a YouTube video called
"98 Minutes of Fire." I
scrubbed through it to see if
there was anything gross, but
you're all adults, you know.
Because YouTube would
never let you down.
That's what I've learned.
So if you guys want to
come to the mics and
line up, that's great.
I have no idea how many of
you we will get to today.
We have 57 minutes
and 41 seconds.
So I'm going to start
with some of
the moderator questions.
Are you guys actually lined up
for questions or are you just
standing around?
I can't tell.
There's no mic back there.
OK, so you're a questioner
guy.
Why don't you kick us off.
Someone here in the room.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
There seems to be a gap between
the build environment
for Eclipse and Ant.
I have, let's say, a plain Java
project that I want to
use in other Java projects,
not just Android projects.
But I also want to use
them in Android.
And it's always kind of a battle
keeping the references
in Eclipse up to date and in
sync with the references in
the Ant file.
So I'm wondering if there's any
way to streamline that or
plans to kind of make them
one in the same.
Xavier Duchrohet: Yes.
In your particular case, since
you have a regular Java
project, you should be able to
just add some custom root to
you Ant file to just reference
that and generate the Java
file and drop it somewhere.
And the project then needs it.
It's kind of crappy.
We are well aware of that.
And we actually looking
currently at revamping the
whole thing to have one single
root system that's shared
across command line, or boot
server, and Eclipse.
AUDIENCE: Cool, that's what
I wanted to know.
CHRIS DIBONA: Let's go for
this fellow over here.
This one's empty, this mic
over here, by the way.
Just so you know.
That one's got 20 people on it.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: With the Chrome
browser now coming on Android,
on Jelly Bean, what happens to
the original Android browser?
Does that get taken out of
the Android open source?
And also, what happens
with WebView?
DAVE BURKE: So the Nexus 7 is
the first device that we
actually pre-installed Chrome.
With the Galaxy Nexus, when you
get an upgrade from Ice
Cream Sandwich to Jelly Bean,
we're not actually going to
pre-install Chrome.
Because some users prefer using
the Android browser,
which has flash support,
for example.
What we are doing is actually
converting the web view that's
in Android to the Chromium-based
code.
So we're actually working on
upstreaming the code right now
into chromium.org.
And so then that WebView will
become one single browser.
And then organizationally,
internally we
sort of combined teams.
So we have Android engineers and
Chrome engineers working
on it together.
So it's a grand unification
in theory.
AUDIENCE: What happens when,
like in the old Android
platform, you couldn't actually
update your browser?
And you couldn't
update WebView.
So does that mean WebView now
will get updated regularly?
DAVE BURKE: No.
Actually, it's a really
good question.
So when a new version of Android
comes out, the WebView
and the Chrome browser will
be one and the same.
They'll use the same WebView.
Then every six weeks, or
whatever it is, that we update
Chrome, we'll update the
Chrome browser APK.
But we won't change
the WebView.
So it will actually be a larger
install because of that.
And the reason we want to do
that is we don't want to risk
any compatibility issues with
people's applications who are
using WebView.
Chrome works really hard to make
sure that every update
that you get is not only on your
desktop, it's backwardly
compatible.
But we're just going to
play very careful.
So they're kind of separated.
CHRIS DIBONA: So I'll take
one from the moderator.
Google Maps SDK for Android is
getting long in the tooth.
Memory leaks, no fragment
support, only a
single map per app.
Any word on improvements?
You got it, Dave.
DAVE BURKE: What can
I say about this?
Yes, we're working on it.
No ETA on launching it.
But totally understood that
the version that's out
there's quite old.
We're just trying to figure out
exactly what it is we're
launching and when we're
launching it.
So I think I just dodged
that question.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Say that my app uses
the support library.
Is there any work to
automatically have that use
the native version
of the APIs?
DIANNE HACKBORN: Some parts of
the support library switch to
the native versions,
some don't.
And that's done based on
what makes most sense.
For example, fragments always
use one of the support
libraries because you really
don't want to get the
different behavior that's
in the platform.
It doesn't really have an impact
on how it runs on the
newer versions, so we decided
that it was best to always use
the one in the support
library.
There's a bunch of other stuff,
though, that lets you
selectively use newer things
in the platform.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How can we
install multiple
versions of the same APK?
Like a product build, a QA
build, and a dev build.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Give them
different package names, I
guess, is the only
answer for that.
AUDIENCE: But that generally
screws up our
version control because--
CHRIS DIBONA: Get better
version control.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS DIBONA: Will the ability
to back up our entire phone to
a computer or some other
local storage be
possible in Jelly Bean?
As I understand, this
is possible
in Ice Cream Sandwich.
Will I be able to
use Android ABB?
So if we're going to answer
that, I'm going to say I'm
going to pick things are more
developer focused going
forward, just so you know.
As opposed to this very--
what I consider a very
user-focused thing.
Users are great, but go ahead.
DIANNE HACKBORN: So the ADD
backup stuff that was put into
Ice Cream Sandwich is
still in Jelly Bean.
There were no changes really
done to it in Jelly Bean.
CHRIS DIBONA: OK, great.
I think I go this
direction here.
AUDIENCE: So my question's about
app discovery on the
Google Play store.
So about one month ago,
I released my app
for the first time.
I only got like 30 downloads.
It's a free app.
If you compare that to releasing
iOS on the first
time, I got like 4,000
downloads.
It's because, I didn't actually
realize, but you guys
removed the 'What's
New' section from
the Google Play store.
So there's no way that users
can find fresh new apps.
So any plans to bring
back 'What's New'?
I know you were getting spammed
a little bit, but
maybe you could fix
the spam somehow.
Get rid of the spam.
MICHAEL SALISKY: The 'What's
New' on a per category basis
is something that we're actively
looking at bringing
back in the future.
For app discovery in general,
that's something that we care
very deeply about.
We know that you all care very
deeply about as well.
So improving, I think, the
storefront and making the apps
that get featured there, making
a much broader and
deeper list, is something
we're looking at.
We also, just today, launched
Recommendations.
And so doing personalized and
social recommedations is
something that we hope will get
a lot more apps in front
of people in a lot more
places as well.
AUDIENCE: So with recent phones
that are running high
resolutions like 1280 by 800,
is there a way to easily
identify if the user device
is a phone or tablet?
Because right now, I couldn't
find a way to do that.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Resolution
doesn't matter, it's DP units.
Actually it's kind of funny.
We have Zoom, Galaxy Nexus,
and now the Nexus 7.
There are all basically 1280
by 800 resolution screens.
But they're very different
devices, and it's because they
had different densities.
So if you convert those to DP
units, then you see that
they're actually very different
screen sizes.
And that's why a lot of the
newer stuff the platform for
selecting different
layouts and stuff
is based on DP units.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question?
So we really like the new
smart app update when we
update the delta of the app.
Is there a way going forward for
the user to only download
the scheduled image drivers for
his own phone resolutions
instead of downloading the
whole applications?
Because there's only one
resolution that will work for
that device, which is kind of
a waste to the user and also
the bandwidth.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: Yeah, I think
that's something that we
want to look at doing.
Right now, we found we got the
most bang for the buck by
doing the deltas
like you said.
The good news there is that the
delta kind of eats up most
of the download that used
to have to take place.
I think you could see a lot less
disk footprint, you're
right, if we scale
things down.
The problem is that we're seeing
a lot of these devices
that can operate in multiple
densities.
Like you plug it in
a TV or something.
So it's a little trickier than
you might think at first
glance, but it's definitely
something we're looking at.
CHRIS DIBONA: Gifting and promo
codes for paid apps and
in-apps purchases please.
One use case is paid gift apps
to people who get to read the
development without a hassle.
[? This is reading ?] updates
outside of Google Play.
So that's sort of update
to Google Play.
MICHAEL SALISKY: Feature
request?
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah it's
a feature request.
MICHAEL SALISKY: I think
that would be great.
CHRIS DIBONA: There you go.
OK, so find that and
start at it.
So we go to you.
AUDIENCE: This kind of ventures
away from being an
app developer, but what would be
the best thing to focus on
learning to eventually become
part of your team?
DAVE BURKE: Skydiving.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS DIBONA: Or rappelling.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So as a developer, WebGL is
really, really exciting.
Firefox and Opera on Android
offer WebGL support today.
In iOS, you can flip a bit and
get WebGL in any WebView.
But for Chrome for Android
and the Android browser,
we don't have it.
So when can we expect it?
DAVE BURKE: Good question.
Internally, I've seen
it working.
I think the basic issue with
WebGL is denial of service and
GPU stability.
So the concern is, you're on
the drive-by web, you hit a
web page, and then
it pegs your GPU.
Either because it's a bug or
because it's malicious.
Or worse it, exposes a GPU bug
and your phone reboots.
And so there's some work
in Chronos to try to
sanatize it, I guess.
Make it safer.
And so we're just kind of
looking at that right now and
trying to figure out if we can
release it in a safe way.
And again, Android's platform
software has to run across
lots and lots of devices.
And some devices have better,
more stable GPUs than others.
So we're just being a little
bit cautious about it.
So I think I just dodged
that puddle again.
We're working on it, I don't
have an ETA, though.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So, very exciting stuff
announced this morning.
However, that's Jelly Bean, and
last time I checked, 7% of
people have still not--
that's the only amount
of people we have
on Ice Cream Sandwich.
So my question is, how are we
going to get more people on
Jelly Bean so that we can
use those features?
DAVE BURKE: Well, we're going to
first give you free devices
for Jelly Bean.
That's one quick way to start.
CHRIS DIBONA: How many
people are at I/O?
DAVE BURKE: So it's a really
good question.
I actually think the
acceleration of ICS, Ice Cream
Sandwich, has been
pretty good.
Because we only released it,
like, literally months ago.
One of the things
we're doing--
I'm going to answer
at the keynote--
is the PDK, so the platform
development kit.
And so what we're trying to do
is get device manufacturers
access to the source that we're
working on earlier.
So that they can actually work
in parallel to us to speed up
the time it takes to get
out a new device.
So that's one of
the initiatives
we're trying to do.
The other thing we're noticing
is there's is a really great
ecosystem built up
around Android.
We're seeing device
manufacturers getting more
Android savvy.
They're really sharp.
They really know what
they're doing.
And so they're actually getting
faster at building devices.
So I think it's going to get
better because of that.
I don't have a silver bullet
to offer other than that.
The other thing is,
I've seen some
distribution curves of versions.
And you've got to remember that
we sort of had that weird
stage where we had Gingerbread
and Honeycomb.
We were kind of like two
versions as we did the tablet
and then we kind of came
back together in ICS.
And so I think that sometimes
skews data
when you look at that.
I think what you're going
to see is ICS
ramp up quite quickly.
And then the delta from ICS to
Jelly Bean, from a device
manufacturer is actually
quite small.
So I think you'll see, then,
the ICS flip to Jelly Bean
more quickly.
That's a prediction.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[FEEDBACK]
AUDIENCE: How much time
do we have to
transition from CT to C--
CD--
Help me out here.
DAVE BURKE: C2DM?
AUDIENCE: Right, to the Google
cloud messaging.
At what point is the new device
registration just going
to stop working on C2DM?
FRED CONTADA: It'll
be a long time.
We'll give you plenty
of heads' up
before that will happen.
AUDIENCE: Like a year?
FRED CONTADA: Like a year.
AUDIENCE: Is there anyone
here who can answer a
render script question?
DAVE BURKE: I can answer
easy ones.
AUDIENCE: Regarding shaders
and variable packing.
DAVE BURKE: Getting nervous.
AUDIENCE: So in writing my
program, I've discovered that
in the data structures that I
create, the render script
seems to be converting Boolean
and int values into floats.
So if I try and execute an if
statement on the structure
member, I end up with an error
message saying that it has to
be a Boolean value.
Obviously I can type cast it in
the shader to fix that, but
the real issue becomes, it
makes it difficult to
properly pack data.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah, I don't
know the answer, but I
know a man who does.
So it just come up to me
afterwards, I'll get your
details and I'll
connect you up.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We've seen a lot of the exciting
stuff from the Google
Maps team today.
And a lot of the stuff is
focused on desktop usage
through a browser.
Now when running that on an
Android smartphone or tablet
you see that from a user
experience point of view, it's
kind of lacking as opposed to
the native MapView component
in Android, up to the
point where it
becomes barely usable.
What is the way forward in that
respect and what should
we do as developers that want
to leverage Google Maps
technologies on Android
devices?
DAN MORRILL: So yeah, let me
just rephrase the question and
make sure I understand
what you're saying.
You're basically pointing out
that there's a lot of features
in maps that are not necessarily
available to
developers via WebView?
AUDIENCE: They are available
via WebView,
but it's really slow.
DAN MORRILL: I'm sorry, not
a WebView, a MapView.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
DAN MORRILL: Yeah, it's
absolutely the case that the
MapView is getting kind
of long in the tooth.
It came from Android 1.0.
The API has not changed
significantly
really since then.
That is, in fact, something
that we're looking at.
We're aware that there's this
increasing functionality gap.
It's just one of those things
as a being kind of a tricky
problem to solve because it's
possible to build a cool, new
version, but then how do
you maintain backwards
compatibility?
Do you maintain backwards
So we don't have a ready answer,
but it actually came
up relatively recently with us
and we're working with GEO
team to figure out what the
right way forward there is.
So we're definitely aware of
that problem and we're looking
into it, but we recognize
it's an issue.
AUDIENCE: And what would
be the guidelines for
developers right now?
DAN MORRILL: For now, if you
can make it work with the
current MapView, go
ahead and do that.
But do whatever works
for your app.
We don't really have a best
practice at this time for what
you should do instead.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
CHRIS DIBONA: So on
the [? dory ?]
it says, on the Nexus 7, the
notification bar and the
system bar are split similar
to phones, rather than
combined such as on current
HCIS devices.
Is a similar setup going
to be used for 10
inch tablets as well?
So this is sort of like, what
happens when the DP
units are to small?
AUDIENCE: What was
the question?
Yeah, could you read
them slower?
CHRIS DIBONA: Sure.
Maybe.
On the Nexus 7, the notification
bar and the
system bar are split similar
to phones, rather than
combined, as on the Zoom.
Is a similar setup going
to be used on future
10-inch devices as well?
DIANNE HACKBORN: Jelly Bean on
a 10-inch tablet uses the
system bar like before.
CHRIS DIBONA: Ok,
so there you go.
Alright.
I talk slowly, they get
really pissed off.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I had a
question about--
more of a hardware question
slash viewpoint from you guys.
Most of my organization uses
iPhones, and I've basically
been persuading them to start
letting people use Android
based phones.
And one of the problems that
we've run into is with all the
different manufacturers and
phone types out there, some
have external media, or external
storage capabilities
and some don't.
And the Nexus doesn't.
And of the other things that's
really been a barrier to entry
for my management team people is
that you can't just plug it
in and mount it like you
can most other--
like the Droid you can,
or the Razr Max.
If you plug it in, it just shows
up like a USB drive.
And with the Nexus, you have to
go into a PTP or MTP mode.
And if you're a Linux user,
that's even more of a headache
than it is on Windows and Mac.
So is there a reason why you
guys chose to do non-block USB
connection?
Or can you to speak to why
that is, and if that's
something that you're going
to continue to move
forward with that?
Or will be a day where it just
mounts like a USB drive?
REBECCA ZAVIN: I think some of
that has to do with, a little
bit, about user experience
around having that mount as a
USB key, essentially.
I don't know that we
have a concrete
plan for moving forward.
I'm looking at Dave.
Yeah.
But I think--
AUDIENCE: Has it been something
that anybody else
has mentioned to you?
Or has that even come up?
REBECCA ZAVIN: We definitely
know that there are some
devices that do USB mass
storage, which is what you're
talking about, and
some that don't.
And that we haven't done it on
our Nexus products recently.
I think there are some really
great user experiences around
PTP, your PPTP and MTP.
But you're right.
You need, like, MTP on Linux
and stuff to get it going.
There are some good tools, but
like doing anything from
desktop Linux, it's a little
bit more complex.
DIANNE HACKBORN: USB mass
storage is kind of crummy.
I don't think we really
want to do it.
It requires, for example, if you
have a 32-gig phone, you
have to partition it into a
hard partition between the
part that would be USB
mass storage and
the part that's not.
And so being able to not have a
FAT file system that has all
the negatives to it that forces
you to do a partition
makes a lot things better.
So we've kind of tended to not
do those in the newer devices.
AUDIENCE: It seems like that's
how the external storage is
like what the Droid does.
That's your USB mass
key is that thing.
Whether you pull it out and
plug it directly into your
machine or you leave it mounted
into your phone, it
just makes it very difficult
for me to convince somebody
that they can't drag and
drop stuff onto it.
So I was curious.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Dragging and
dropping, I think, is probably
the host side's software
problem.
There's no reason why you
wouldn't be able to have it
all working.
The iPhone does not use USB mass
storage, I don't think.
CHRIS DIBONA: There's no way
to create an x86 emulator
using, quote, "API level 15 or
any other API level." This
prevents us from using an Intel
emulator to develop apps
that use maps, for example.
Is support for the Google APIs
coming to that architecture?
AUDIENCE: What was
the question?
CHRIS DIBONA: Sorry.
Basically, support of x86 for
the APIs and the emulator.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So
we are aware that.
Intel is actually the one who
worked a lot on making the
kernel for the emulator
work on x86 well.
And so they've been
contributing some
patches back to us.
So at some point, we do intend
to see if we can actually
release that.
Something we haven't released,
a Jelly Bean system image
running x86, we're working
with Intel to be able to
release that.
But right now, it's kind of
like we're not in total
control, because we
depend on them on
helping us fix some issues.
But as soon as we can do
it, we'll release that.
AUDIENCE: I do Android
development on atypical devices.
Not tablets, not phones.
CHRIS DIBONA: Pacemakers?
AUDIENCE: Say what?
AUDIENCE: Media set-top boxes.
Specifically for
entertainment-based apps and
digital signage, that
sort of thing.
And one of my biggest headaches
is the media player.
I'm aware, for technical and
legal reasons, that you can't
just have one beautiful
media player that
works across all devices.
Anyway, so I get all these
different devices, and they
always have some different media
player under the hood
that works different.
The performance is
weird, scales
weird, it buffers weird.
There's something I have to--
whatever shipment of boxes has
to work very differently.
I've tried several open-source
media players that use NDK and
they've been buggy and also
had performance problems.
And so I was wondering, with
your greater awareness of the
Android world, if you are aware
of any open-source media
player projects that could
possibly reduce my headache.
DAVE BURKE: So what version
of Android is this?
AUDIENCE: 4.0.
Or yeah, 4.0.2.
DAVE BURKE: So it really comes
down to the hardware decoders
and encoders that you're
struggling with.
The Android framework, the media
framework's built on
something called Stagefright and
then the media player sits
on top of that.
We just introduced some new
Jelly Bean APIs called
MediaCodec.
Actually, James just came
from a talk on that.
AUDIENCE: I was in that talk.
DAVE BURKE: Cool, ok
so you got it.
The issue, though, is that we
just mandate different codecs,
different profiles, but after
that it's really up to the
implementations.
And so it is true that there's
some variability on the
hardware codecs.
If we could standardize on them
and just go, here's the
codec, we would.
But that would mean it would be
software and you wouldn't
have the performance.
But I think, maybe the right
answer is getting more tests
on our side to make sure
that issues you
run into we can control.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious,
are you aware of any
open-source projects
out there for it?
CHRIS DIBONA: Not any of the
ones that you haven't already
checked out, like
MPlayer and VLC.
We know you're looking
at that, right.
And they're having
their issues.
DAVE BURKE: And open
source will be
software-based codecs, probably.
And so you won't get
the performance.
CHRIS DIBONA: They tie in to
the GPUs a little bit, but
it's a pretty challenging
area.
Yeah, I haven't heard of any
special program just for
Android in the open source world
that's addressed this
any better than, say feel
VLC or MPlayer.
REBECCA ZAVIN: If it makes you
feel any better, James and I
both spend a significant amount
of our time making this
work well on the devices
that we ship.
So you're not alone.
AUDIENCE: That's good to know.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I work on a Scala
plug-in to make it easy to run
Scala code on Android devices.
And one of the things that has
to happen is the shrink step
in ProGuard so you get something
that can be dexed.
But I end up with the full Scala
library that I'd like to
use at code completion time, and
then a minified version of
that but I want you to dex.
Is there a way to hook into the
Eclipse build tool to do
that so I could make this a
really nice experience for
someone just starting out of the
box not using Ant or Maven
or something like that?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Not at the
moment, but we can talk after
and we can open up some
extension point for you to do
that if you want.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So in the radio interface layer
with the Android source
code, there's references
made to RIL
version 4 of the interface.
And then it says at the current
version is version 6
and I assume it goes all
the way back to 1.
But I haven't been able to find
any references to the
documentation specifically
for this interface.
And by proxy, the AT command set
that the radio interface
supports, can we just assume
that that's a subset of the
standard AT commands, or are
any of the newer commands
supported for SMS or MMS?
DAVE BURKE: You're looking
for documentation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, basically.
DAVE BURKE: Oh.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
DAVE BURKE: Yeah, we don't have
as much documentation.
Actually, for the PDK, we're
trying to build more
documentation.
Because what you're talking
about the real level is really
PDK-level stuff.
To your question about the Hayes
commands, I don't know
the answer.
I'm not sure if anyone else--
Rebecca, if you know?
REBECCA ZAVIN: I think it is
a subset, but I don't know.
DAVE BURKE: I think it's also
very radio-dependent, as well.
REBECCA ZAVIN: We do
support a subset of
AT commands, I think.
AUDIENCE: I guess the question,
basically, for the
AT stuff was, can we assume that
the AT commands that work
across all devices are on
Android and that there aren't
any special ones for Android?
REBECCA ZAVIN: I think that's
probably a safe assumption
based on the way that we
interact with our partners who
build radios.
But I don't know for sure.
That's a good question to ask
on the mailing lists.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I downloaded the last Google+
version and it's actually
really cool with that
menu that opens up.
And I was wondering, it's a UI
pattern that was first seen in
the Facebook application.
I was wondering, if at some
point, we might get something
like that in the support
library.
Because it's really cool and it
has been implemented across
different apps in
different ways.
And I'm just waiting
for one standard.
DIANNE HACKBORN: No plans
at this point.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVE BURKE: It's a good
idea, though.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: Spotify does
it really well.
Have you seen the spotify app?
Yeah, it's good.
So does YouTube, actually.
The latest version.
No, not YouTube, Google+.
Oh, and YouTube.
So we do, yeah good idea.
AUDIENCE: Regarding the PDK
that's being released, is that
going to be targeting
the Android
open-source platform as well?
Or is that primarily for OEM?
DAVE BURKE: Right now
it's targeted
towards OPMs, basically.
One of the problems is we're
kind of a finite-sized team,
and so we have to be careful.
If we were interacting with
everybody while developing, we
would just slow down.
And so we decided we would try
this approach where we make it
available to device
manufacturers.
The explicit goal is to speed up
getting devices to market.
That's our first goal.
AUDIENCE: Is there going to be
any increased support, I
guess, on the Android
open-source side of things?
DAVE BURKE: That's kind
of [? orthogonal ?]
to the PDK.
AUDIENCE: All right, I know
you addressed the Android
software updates earlier.
But I was wondering, whatever
happened to the Android update
alliance which guaranteed, with
OEMs, upgrades in two
months after release
of device?
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: Did we
say two months?
CHRIS DIBONA: I think that might
have been in base-10.
Thought it was base-16.
DAVE BURKE: It was 18 months.
So I think what we
said last year--
and I wasn't here last year--
what we said last year was, we
would make sure that devices
got supported for 18 months,
and so we're
certainly doing that.
It hasn't been 18 months since
last year, so you can't prove
or disprove if it's
working yet.
It's an important thing.
CHRIS DIBONA: They're going
to call you in December.
You know that, right?
DAVE BURKE: Really?
It's a good question.
It's something we're working
with partners hard on.
AUDIENCE: In Jelly Bean you have
the ability to disable
notifications per application
base.
Do you have any plans to extend
it to more permissions?
Like, say I don't want a certain
application to have
internet access anymore.
DIANNE HACKBORN: No.
No, we don't.
CHRIS DIBONA: So the
answer's no.
AUDIENCE: One thing I find
difficult to do is create
package UI components to share
among different applications.
Are there any plans to
make that easier?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Do you want
to show them just at the
compilation level, or
do you want it to be
installed on the device?
Because we're doing that.
You have Android library
projects.
So that second one, I
don't think Dianne
will say yes to that.
But the first one, we support
that at the compilation level.
If you look up Android library
project, you can share code
and resources.
AUDIENCE: Right, but you have
to actually, at least as far
as I know, you have to
include that in your
workspace in Eclipse.
Or, it's very difficult to
package that off and give it
to someone as just a
jar, for example.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Right, so we
do want to go with binary
distribution of that.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
XAVIER DUCROHET: So, apparently,
IntelliJ allows
you to do that, so you
should look it up.
Or Maven.
We do want to support that
directly, natively in the SDK
build system.
But, yes there are third
parties, support that do that
and you should try them.
AUDIENCE: So is there any plans
to support natively?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
CHRIS DIBONA: There are two
questions in the moderator
that are very, very similar.
And they come down to support
for the Now cards, which is
what they call them.
Basically, support for user
applications you get into the
Now stream, and tying into
Android side navigation.
Asking if there's going to be
support in the future SDKs for
some of the new elements.
Make sense?
DAVE BURKE: We have no
plans at the moment.
CHRIS DIBONA: No plans
at the moment.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So the biggest thing that I find
that people coming into
the platform as developers from
other systems, and as
well as demands coming from
clients, is to show a lot of
downloaded URLs as images.
So dealing with bitmaps, and
image views, and list views,
and all that kind of stuff.
And staying within the memory
allowment that we have, as
well as dealing with the fact
that images are built in on
the native side and then brought
over to the Java side
and all that kind of stuff.
Anyways, the point is, it's a
really hard problem to solve.
And I look at your apps
and they're fantastic.
And you've solved them in
some really clever ways.
So are you guys going
to open-source that?
Well, not open-source
that, because it's
already open source.
But more bring it to a level
where beginner developers can
have access to that kind of
reliability of a, caching, b,
having nice crisp images and
not having to downsample.
And also speed when it comes
to downloading and all that
kind of stuff.
RETO MEIER: So one thing which
we are trying to do is pick up
a lot of these best practices
and make them available as
development training on
the newly redesigned
developer.android.com site.
So if you have a look at the
training section there, I
think we have a class now
which talks about how to
download bitmaps efficiently.
If not, then I guess
that's something
which is coming soon.
We're definitely trying to
collect up that knowledge,
that best practice, and make it
more readily available to
developers which don't want to
have to troll through all of
the open-source code
themselves.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: We actually
also have a ready-made jar for
exactly this thing that's
coming soon.
It's just not ready yet.
But the idea is that a really
typical pattern is you have a
list view and an adapter and it
has thumbnails and you're
getting them from the network
and you need to deal with
recycling the views
and everything.
We're hoping to have something
kind of plug and play you can
link in your app soon, it
just wasn't ready today.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Is it anywhere in your
site to just increase the
amount of memory we have
access to as an app?
DIANNE HACKBORN: The memory
has been increasing pretty
regularly, especially as the
screen sizes increase.
There also was added in--
Honeycomb was the option to
set a large memory size.
So if you have applications
that do need a lot of RAM,
they can say that they want to
have a higher memory limit.
It's always a trade-off between
the RAM for that
application and, it could be
used elsewhere to keep other
applications around so you don't
have slow switches to
other applications.
So we do want developers to pay
a lot of attention to the
RAM use and not just gratiously
go, I'm going to
use a bunch of RAM because
it's easier.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I might have missed
this during the keynote, but
are there going to be any APIs
for the new Voice Search and
Google Now that we can access?
DAVE BURKE: That was a question
that you read out,
but no one understood you.
No.
AUDIENCE: And also, just kind
of off-topic, that I was
reminded of on my way here
from Sacramento.
I used to have separate volumes
for navigation and
that disappeared after
Gingerbread .
Is there any way to have
something like that back?
CHRIS DIBONA: We found people
just weren't listening.
DAVE BURKE: James
is saying no.
I'm going to hand you
over to James.
JAMES: No.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE BURKE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One of the things
that I've liked that was
introduced in one of the more
recent Android developer tools
was the Lint error checking.
And is there any thoughts on
allowing the developers to
have their own test
cases, basically?
For instance, to make sure that
a texture always has a
color set, or something
like that.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes.
We actually have
an API for it.
We just haven't actually
finished integrating that into
the Lint tool so that it picks
up jar coming from you.
But it's ready.
We just need to finish that.
AUDIENCE: What is the best way
of merging the data from your
own content provider with
data from other
content providers available?
Performing some computation on
that data beyond simple joins,
and then feeding that data
into an adapter, cursor
adapter, for instance, and
displaying a place view or
something What do
you recommend?
Because I've been struggling
with this.
DIANNE HACKBORN: It
depends a lot on
exactly what you're doing.
AUDIENCE: For instance, I know
there is CursorJoiner,
MagicCursor, MergeCursor,
or something like that.
But I don't know which is the
best way of integrating data
from multiple providers
on the fly.
DIANNE HACKBORN: I don't know
the details of all those
different helper classes.
Basically you're going to want
to do something so that, as
you iterate through the
different cursors, that you
don't have to look ahead.
ideally, you'd want to be able
to basically keep a position
for each of the cursors and just
returned the next result.
Because if you start to look
ahead, then you're going to
have to do big queries
across all of them.
And if you have a lot of data,
then you have to re-query as
you go down the cursor.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but how do I--
For instance, I want to merge
something from my own provider
with something from the
contact's contract and display
that in a list view.
So far, what I did is manually
doing that and putting all the
data in MagicCursor, and then
feeding that to CursorAdapter.
But what I found strange is that
you can put anything in
MagicCursor, you can put any
kind of object, but you can
only take out primitives
and strings, basically.
Why is that?
Why is it this limitation?
DIANNE HACKBORN: I
don't know that.
DAVE BURKE: We have office
hours, actually.
I think they're on
tomorrow as well.
So this is kind of like an
in-depth question, but if you
go there I'm sure there's
somebody who
can probably help.
So I think it's on the third
floor, Android office hours.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can an Android APK package
be signed with multiple
certificates?
DIANNE HACKBORN: You can do it,
but you really should not.
DAVE BURKE: That's
Dianne saying no.
DIANNE HACKBORN: The model is,
you have your own self-signed
certificate, and that is your
identity, and that is the one
you should use to
sign your APK.
AUDIENCE: Let's say I have a
dependency on some third-party
vendor, and so I'll have to
get it signed by them.
So say my version one doesn't
have that, and say my version
one has a certificate
that is what I own.
And my version two, I depend
on some third-party vendor
because I'll have to give
it to them for signing.
How do you manage that, or is
that manageable at all?
DIANNE HACKBORN: If you're
signing it with a different
certificate, then it is
a different identity.
It's a completely different
application, and so you can't
treat it as the same thing.
You should give it a different
package name.
AUDIENCE: OK.
One more question.
Is there an in-build WebView
kind of a thing that can
render or open documents
securely within your
application?
DAVE BURKE: I think it's
intent-based right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
intent-based.
So I don't want to give the
documents that are there
within my application to some
other application for opening,
because they can do anything
with their document.
I want the security of opening
or viewing the document.
Other than [INAUDIBLE]
a document viewer, is there
any other way that I can
somehow render a document
in my--
DIANNE HACKBORN: There's
just WebView.
And of course, TextView.
AUDIENCE: Well, for TextView
even, you have to write your
parses for whatever format
is directed.
Say you have a PDF document,
then you'll have to write your
parses for extracting
the text and then
rendering it in TextView.
So apart from [? breaking ?]
that, is there something?
DAVE BURKE: Not today.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a big fan of library
projects,
which are quite awesome.
But my workspace got really
messy lately with have
ActionBarSherlock having version
four, version 3.5.
And I tried to solve if with
Android maven again, but IDT
doesn't take the dot ApkLib file
as a library project, so
I have to switch again
the library from
one version to another.
So do you plan to manage
that kind of file?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes we do want
to support the binary
distribution similar
to ApkLib.
I don't know if it will be
exactly the same, but it's
pretty simple.
So we will would probably
support that at some point in
the future but not right now.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In terms of portability and
performance, it's hard to beat
native code.
But here at Google I/O,
it doesn't seem to be
getting much love.
Why is that?
DAVE BURKE: In terms of
portability, it's hard
to beat Java code.
AUDIENCE: Not on iOS.
DAVE BURKE: That's because
you don't have all
the different hardware.
It's a good question.
The problem is that Android is
a program that runs across
lots of different types
of hardware.
And so we favor Java because it
gives you that portability.
The problem is if you write
everything in native, then you
have different types
of ARM CPUs.
You now have x86 CPUs.
You're going to have new
architectures in the future,
and so it's not as portable.
DIANNE HACKBORN: And there's
a render script, too, as an
alternative.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
have you guys
considered buying Swipe?
DAVE BURKE: Let me open up the
financial statements at Google
and explain where we are.
What?
AUDIENCE: I just think it's
the greatest keyboard.
My dad, who's technically
not into it, if you
will, to put it nicely.
He loves and he uses
it every day.
So if he can use it, I think it
just kind of speaks to how
great a keyboard it is.
DAVE BURKE: It's funny.
I see some people really love
it, and other people like the
more traditional ones.
But, yeah, I definitely
shouldn't talk about
acquisitions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK.
Good.
DIANNE HACKBORN: We put a lot
of work into the implemented
framework to allow you to
replace the keyboard.
And so I think it's actually
great that they have a great
keyboard that you go and buy,
and support them, and use it
if you want to.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
they're not in
the market and they're--
DIANNE HACKBORN: So you should
talk with them about going
into the market.
AUDIENCE: That's why I'm telling
you guys to buy them.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question related
to enterprise apps.
I was wondering if the panel can
share if there is any plan
to open up API to manage
802.1x key management?
And I'm especially interested
in on-campus networks.
DAVE BURKE: I think you
successfully stumped the panel.
Sorry, we don't have
anyone from our
enterprise group here.
DAN MORRILL: That's actually a
different group within Google.
So we don't really have
an answer to that.
CHRIS DIBONA: Is this the
Cisco thing again?
The Cisco 802.1x stuff?
AUDIENCE: 802.11 on-campus
networks.
So, whereby--
CHRIS DIBONA: I think Cisco
actually did some drivers.
I'm not vouching for them.
But you might want
to talk to them.
They might have something
for you.
Like I said, I haven't used it
myself, but I remember them
having a similar problem.
AUDIENCE: Understood,
thank you.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, so I would
look for them online.
AUDIENCE: I'm really excited
about the announcement about
the PDK this morning as
a device manufacturer.
And I have a question
about it.
They say it took two to three
months to apply to release it
open-source.
And the other question is, in
case we look at the two to
three months that's
before release, it
must be immature Android.
And how can you describe the
difference between current
Jelly Bean and two, three
months before?
How can you describe it?
DAVE BURKE: So it's still
really early.
What we're going to try
to do is, let me see
if I have this right.
We want to get into a rhythm
where let's say you have a
device brought up
on Jelly Bean.
So you've got the Jelly
Bean open-source.
And we're working on K,
whatever that is.
Any suggestions for
names, by the way?
AUDIENCE: Key lime,
key lime pie.
DAVE BURKE: What?
Keyline?
OK.
Keyli--
Keyline.
So, we're working on Keylah--
What?
MICHAEL SALISKY: Key lime.
Key lime pie.
DAVE BURKE: Oh, key lime pie.
OK.
So we're working on Key Lime--
it's not official, everybody.
So imagine we're
working on 'K'.
What we want to do is make sure
that your device that's
already running on Jelly Bean
can actually start running on
an early version of K. So we
want to make sure that the
HAL, the hardware abstraction
layer, is forward compatible.
Did I get that right, Rebecca?
I think I did.
And so the result is that it
should be much quicker to
bring up your device on
the next version.
And then we finally drop the
full source and open-source,
your device should basically
be up and running.
That's the idea.
The specifics of how this all
works and the exact timing,
like is it two months, is it
three months et cetera, we're
still working that out.
This is our first cycle
through it.
I think we mentioned this
morning we've already given
some of our partners the PDK.
So it's very much a work in
progress, but it's looking
kind of promising, so far.
REBECCA ZAVIN: And to be clear,
that doesn't work
today, the forward
compatibility of the HAL layers.
That's something that
we're working on.
But the goal is for you to
someday be able to run your
JBSB, if you're a [? southern ?]
vendor, against
K and vice versa.
But, like I said,
that's a goal.
AUDIENCE: And in case of,
talking about the hardware
abstraction layer, the
participation of the chipset
vendor is very important.
And in case the device is, for
example, our chipset is not
the one for use for
the Nexus devices.
Do you see the major
chipset vendors
participating in the program?
REBECCA ZAVIN: We've already
taken some feedback on things
in the PDK, or things that were
missing from the PDK,
from some of the partners
we've shared with.
And the Nexus devices are
not all on one chip set.
So I think we have some
experience, now, with making
these kinds of effort
to work across
different kinds of hardware.
That's something that, in the
beginning, we were kind of a
Qualcomm house, and we didn't
know how to do that.
But I think we've gotten
a lot better at it.
So we're definitely going to
be taking feedback on it.
The systems team is interested
on making your life easier and
making it easier to
bring up Android.
It makes our lives easier,
because we bring up Android on
new hardware, too.
So we're actively interested
in what are the holes, what
needs to be that isn't there,
what's there that you wish
weren't there, things
like that.
And how your time to bringing
up a new Android release on
your hardware can
be shortened.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Thank you.
CHRIS DIBONA: Just so you know,
Key Lime's not official.
I think we should let Krispy
Kreme and Kit Kat bid against
each other.
It would be auction-based.
It would be very Google-y.
DAVE BURKE: I like Key Lime.
AUDIENCE: When will the
'requires smallest width DP'
attribute in the manifest
actually be used for filtering
in Google Play?
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: Soon.
I don't have a good answer for
you on that right now.
It's been kind of a trial
migrating from the old screen
size buckets to the newer and
better smallest-width stuff.
But, soon.
It's on our radar.
AUDIENCE: I just thought it
was odd that it was--
I saw it there, and I thought,
oh great I can not have it be
downloadable on certain
devices.
And then I put it in and
it didn't seem to work.
And then I realized that
it's not actually
being used for filtering.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
I agree with you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But
DAVE BURKE: I was thinking
more about the desserts.
What if we started
going backwards?
Like, we go like J and then go
I and then start going to H.
That would kind of be fun.
Do you think I threw them off?
CHRIS DIBONA: No, I'm
actually all for it.
I think we're going to be really
stuck at Z, and then
we'll just have to go
backwards anyway.
Switch over to umlauts,
you know.
DAN MORRILL: Sooner or later,
we have a modular problem.
So we might as well just the
bullet now and start--
CHRIS DIBONA: There's probably
some German desserts that have
umlauts that we could use.
DAVE BURKE: That could work.
CHRIS DIBONA: But that's
not they're here for.
AUDIENCE: Asking about the audio
manager APIs within ICS.
It seems the notification stream
and the ringer stream
have kind of combined into one,
even though they're not
combined in the API.
You get a lot of users who
complain about that.
Maybe you could explain the
thought behind that.
DAVE BURKE: It was a user
experience decision.
Do we have anyone
from UX here?
Nope.
AUDIENCE: I've got a lot of
users who don't like the
experience.
I prefer the experience, but
when it was a configuration
option before, you left
it up to the user.
And now they don't
have a choice.
DAVE BURKE: We have an internal
meme, which, whenever
this topic comes up--
and somebody will always post
a picture, which is, 'add
another setting.' And then they
show this picture of this
huge mixing desk.
So I think the UX guys were
basically trying to simplify
the experience.
I think there are some group of
people who want that extra
level of control.
I don't know what the right
answer is, but, yeah, we're
aware of the feedback.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAN MORRILL: Another thing to
point out there is, yeah, you
get you get complaints from
users who want the
flexibility.
We got, probably, even more
complaints from users who
didn't understand what
was going on.
And so we totally hear where
you're coming from on UX
decisions like that.
But our decision making process
includes the broadest
number of users possible.
And so I'm just putting that
out, just to kind of consider
both sides of the
coin as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi, just a statement
and a question.
First the statement.
I think Key Lime Pie
is a great name.
They're very delicious.
DAN MORRILL: We decided
we're going backwards.
It's I next now.
AUDIENCE: So my question is, I'm
working on a suite of apps
that are not for consumer use.
We want to control what
applications you're running on
the device.
In particular, we want to
prevent users from getting to
the browser in the settings,
and possibly Angry Birds.
Because people shouldn't be
doing that at this time.
Anyways, digressing.
We have a service that is
running a thread that is
scanning the log rapidly to see
when an application has
been started.
And if one of the blacklisted
applications is started, we
switch out of it and kill it.
I feel it's a really
clunky way.
It's probably going to drain
the battery really quickly.
Is there a more elegant
way to do this?
DIANNE HACKBORN: Yeah, so from
the platforms perspective,
that's a malicious
application.
AUDIENCE: That's why I said
not for consumer use.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Yeah, so you'll
find, over time that
the platform has gotten much
more aggressive about finding
things doing that kind of stuff
and stopping them from
disrupting the user experience
like that.
The answer, at this point, is
that you need to do your own
build of Android that has
these restrictions.
We don't have an application API
to do that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: So are you saying
that our solution will
probably stop working
in future?
DIANNE HACKBORN: I would
not count on
it to continue working.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
DAN MORRILL: Actually,
I think it probably
broke in Jelly Bean.
DAVE BURKE: Now that you tell
Dianne about it, it's
definitely not going
to keep working.
CHRIS DIBONA: It sounds like
he wants to start his own
build team, so.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just wondering if anybody on
the panel can speak to any
upcoming changes in Dalvik.
Maybe some optimizations in
the Git, JC optimizations
coming up in Jelly Bean.
DAVE BURKE: Not right now.
AUDIENCE: No answer?
OK.
CHRIS DIBONA: I don't think we
have the right people up here.
DAVE BURKE: We don't have anyone
from the Dalvik team
today, sorry.
CHRIS DIBONA: I would find them
during the office hours
and hammer them on that.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Very nice to meet you.
I do, in fact, have one kind
of performance issue.
Sometimes, we've found
that one's system
memory is very low.
I think it is less
than two megs.
It's very easy to find that
the tablet could reset.
We checked the logs.
It's always matching the
widget or codec in the
[? detector. ?]
The response from, for example,
the activity manager
service, some core service.
I want to know, is it
normal behavior?
Or do you encounter this kind
of issue on your side?
DIANNE HACKBORN: You mean two
megs of RAM across the entire
system is free?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
The result is, the system
server was killed.
DIANNE HACKBORN: That sounds
like a device that doesn't
have enough RAM.
There's the out of memory
killer that has these
parameters for when it kills
processes and stuff.
And it will not kill the system
process unless it's
very, very, very--
It should never kill
the system process.
So there's something going wrong
there, that, either the
out of memory killer
is not working or
something like that.
This is kind of a debugging
thing that we probably can't
really address here.
AUDIENCE: I feel a
little strange.
Normally, this program is
awkward when we play the
[? peak ?] game.
And so normally, no memory
kill should work.
It's very strange.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Could you find
me after this and I can
talk with you about it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
No problem, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So on the Honeycomb
tablet, we found a lot of
issues with video playback and
segmentation for issues.
So we found the same issue
addressed in the Ice Cream
Sandwich and also
the [? Eclair ?]
[? beta ?].
Is there a way for you guys to
push the Ice Cream Sandwich
for an old device to make sure
the future one is updated to
the same level.
Because it was very difficult
to develop when Honeycomb
stopped doing so well.
JAMES: Well the different
devices have different
hardware accelerated
codecs on it.
So that's difficulty for us to
enforce, say, the same level
of performance across
different devices.
But one thing we probably can
improve is, in the future, we
will probably provide somthing
like a profile based CTS test,
so that we can say this device
passes this profile.
Meaning like a medium
performance, or another one
passes another profile.
So that we probably can provide
guidance to the user
of the device.
AUDIENCE: But I think it's a bug
in the system for my case.
Because it is running into a
segmentation fault when I have
a continuous playback.
So I assume there's a
bug fix to the older
device or the tablet.
Or making sure they updated Ice
Cream Sandwich, because it
seems to fix it.
JAMES: OK.
Then that probably seems like
a bug in a driver, maybe.
AUDIENCE: So, you guys don't
have a plan for, for example,
the Zoom or like an older
Galaxy to fix that?
JAMES: Well for the Jelly Bean
release, we actually have a
refresh to Zoom device.
Also, even for a
Nexus S device.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I like doing library
apps a lot.
But sometimes, you can have a
suite of apps and they all
have the same core.
And it seems like including the
library in every single
one of them is excessive, it's
just bloating each one.
Is there any plans of allowing
something like a dependency on
application someplace?
So that if you want to install
one APK it depends on another
one or it can just
download both.
And then if I install a second
one, which is also depending
on that APK, it's already there,
it doesn't have to
download it.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
I'll take this.
Short answer, no.
I think that if you look back
at something like Windows,
with all the VB runtime deals or
whatever, you can see where
this ends up, right.
And we're trying to learn from
the previous mistakes of
others, right.
You end up with app A and app B,
and one of them depends on
some particular bug
compatibility
mode and that thing.
So it is a trade-off, right?
You trade a little bloat for
statically linking, versus
knowing that the thing that you
shipped with stays that
way forever.
Now again, I think there are
things where we make that
trade off in the platform.
We add new APIs and things like
that, and it's expected
be backward compatible.
But the short version is,
we think it would
just become a mess.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
CHRIS DIBONA: So this is
probably our last question.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
So, low latency audio.
We've heard quite a bit
about it today.
What kind of improvements are
we seeing in Jelly Bean?
What percentage?
How fast?
And also, beyond that, the low
latency manifest flag and when
it's actually going to be,
maybe, useful or anyone's
going to use it or care.
DAVE BURKE: So what
did you hear about
audio latency today?
AUDIENCE: They'd been mentioning
it in the Android
chat this morning.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah, it's
a work in progress.
So to give you a bit
of color on it--
We introduced [? Micala ?]
fast mixer.
So for soundpool, tone
generator, and open SL, will
actually run through
a fast mixer, which
will reduce the latency.
Now it turns out the latency
targets we're going for,
they're sub 10 milliseconds
on warm audio playback.
Once you start getting into that
level, anything at all
that's in the system that's
preempting you becomes
problematic.
And so we're now at the level
of devic-dependent issues.
So on the Galaxy Nexus, I think
or latency's gone from
about 100 milliseconds in Ice
Cream Sandwich down to about
12 milliseconds.
But that's not good enough.
We want it to be below 10,
and we want all our
devices below 10.
And all our other devices they
we're updating to Jelly Bean
are not as good as that, for
various reasons that we're
working on.
And so I think you'll see,
in the next update
we'll do even better.
We want to get to a point where
we mandate a minimum,
excuse me, a maximum latency.
And we're just not quite there
yet, but we're making good
progress toward it.
AUDIENCE: And are you going
to be working with any
manufacturers in particular to
encourage the drivers to be
fast and this type of--
DAVE BURKE: Yeah, definitely.
One of the tools I mentioned
at the keynote this morning
was Systrace, where you can
actually look into the system
and see what's happening.
We originally built that for--
We call it jack busting,
not butter, by the way.
That was a marketing term.
So we built that for jack
busting, and it turns out
that's actually really good
or audio as well.
If you had a glitch in audio,
you can see what happened in
the system.
Like, maybe Wi-Fi driver thread
was running at a higher
priority than the auido thread
and starved it, et cetera.
Or there was a hot-swap
of a CPU in or out.
And so we're working
through all the
different issues, basically.
So watch the space, it
will get better.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
CHRIS DIBONA: And that's all
of our time for today.
Thanks to the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS DIBONA: If you have any
further questions, there will
be office hours tomorrow, it
sounds like, as well as people
milling about to help you.